now for an update following russia's
advancement in the southern region of
ukraine we're going to go to the map
with bill hemmer host of america's
newsroom bill it's an honor to be at the
map good to be with you i'm
begging you to let me stand next to you
with the map because i have so many
questions show me where the action is
right down here
uh this is mario paul there were talks
earlier today that the russians wouldn't
allow for these evacuation routes yes
but most of them led to belarus and
russia and the ukrainians said forget
about it right they're looking for
evacuation routes that can take people
out into the western part of ukraine why
is that because of mario pole right now
right now this town is getting hammered
yeah okay how that is well the
ukrainians describe it as medieval times
okay the city of 450 000 people the red
cross believes at least 200 000 want to
get out right now
there's no electricity uh hospitals are
said to have no medicine they're
operating sometimes without anesthesia
oh boy there's no phone service there
are people walking around this town
asking do you know so and so who lived
that so and so are they still alive are
they still there so that's what's
happening inside of mary and they're
moving west and they're moving on odessa
why is that so significant it's economic
it will be significant once they get
there is a town of a million people so
it's one of the top five largest towns
in the entire country they're not there
yet though they've really been stymied
right here at mikolav and this is this
is where the and the pentagon said this
today this is about where they were on
friday night so about 48 hours not a lot
of progress in the south that's good
news they have made progress but over
the last two days it has been what it
has been can i take you to what i think
i'm going to see in a year or so if you
come and take odessa and then you come
across here to moldova that'll fall fast
you have that province there with
russian accents
right so they inflame a little action
there and then these mountains bill
carpathian mountains carpathian
mountains
turkey
has invaded through this bessebarian or
whatever you call it this invasion
corridor this gap how many times a
couple times they had to shut that off
that's where they're after well there is
a section here transnistria already has
at least 1500 russian troops they've
been there for years so and maybe your
theory serves true but i i think what is
significant on the battlefront tonight i
would point to two areas this little
sliver right here that leads to another
nuclear power plant
in the southern part of the country
yeah just keep an eye on that okay the
other thing up here north and east of uh
the capital city you keep this is
largely countryside see how the maps
moved a little bit the russian army has
moved pretty easily here not a lot of
resistance once they got through this
line um so they're they're moving toward
the east of kiev
the northwest side has been much more
difficult if i got a moment i'll show it
to you okay capital city is down here
urping it was where that bridge was
blowing up over the weekend he had two
kids and two adults that were hit by a
missile yeah trying to evacuate i'm it's
absolutely absurd it's about 16 miles
from the capital center the air base is
about 20 miles okay so what is north of
the air base
the convoy that runs for 40 miles north
and now we believe that there are no
tanks in this convoy it's all supply
mechanisms to help with the siege on
keys all right that's what we think the
state of play is all right stay to play
thanks so much bill hemmer excellent
reporting we love it hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else